this aircraft is really is really new is
part of what we call Signature Series
and is we bought the first one in 2016
now we have nine here for Europe and we
will have a twelve by the year-end and
worldwide we have 60 of these aircraft
so that means that we believe a lot that
is the right choice is a midsize cabin
well appreciated from the market for the
comforter you're seeing also now they
know I see the pressurization that is a
really big improvement on compared to
the average of the market we are by many
of these sources in the United States we
have options for up to 200 of these
aircraft so it's a really huge
investment worldwide so and so far the
answer is great this certification that
we got recently in the London City
Airport is also great because you know
the business community is there and you
said you've got 60 days because almost
700 times around the world you know but
fifth biggest place in the world but
they would be surprised by that there
was this company become
we have been growing in the time from a
service point of view let's say
personalization point of view for us
each customer is really a name with the
story behind we try really to cope with
his expectation it's not just a sentence
is their reality because we are forced
also to do that Asia is in our DNA so I
think that was a good strategy based on
safety service availability and this
business model of the ownership they
sure don't you talk about the sort of
plans you have who are they
they businesses that want to move their
executives around the worlds at very
rich individuals those people who's
using these planes when we're not yeah
we have both nor this kind of people we
like to have corporates let's say
companies as customers we have a lot of
individual source now with their family
with the kids with their path consider
last year we we had more than 80
thousand passengers America and 7,000
where kids children 2300 paths you
actually have 6% of the european market
so there's obviously a lot of like at
work out in the next years have you that
there is an under penetration in many
markets Germany for me is an example
where we are good but we have a lot of
opportunity if we compare our market
share and our penetration to the wealthy
that we have in that country and the
ultra high-net-worth individuals that
are there there is a potential expansion
of the new geographies for instance
there is let's say Dubai or North Africa
where we can be we can consider more and
we can be more successful and landing
okay good we are good not just designed
by the pouch half way your ultimate boss
is Warren Buffett what's that like yeah
we like that this is we like that
because this is very important from an
our financial strength you know we have
huge investments we have we are not that
wonderful profit because it's very
costly expensive to do this business a
lot of but we definitely we are
important from also for Berkshire from
capital for the asset that we have